[Music]
the following program contains the
opinions of its host and guests not
those of this network the opinions
expressed are for non-commercial
informational purposes only listeners
are cautioned not to rely on program
content to treat or prevent disease but
are advised to consult with a licensed
health care professional where they live
for diagnosis and treatment of disease
and now the superstar of alternative
health and purveyor of medical truth dr.
Joel Wallach good morning good evening
wherever you may be and welcome to the
dead doctors don't my radio program
pharmacist Ben here sitting in for dr.
Wallach today and thanks for joining us
on the dead doctors don't lie program
will get your phone calls at the bottom
of the hour as we always do we've got
plenty of lines open for you today three
one six eight five ten eighty eight
three one six eight five ten eighty or
triple eight three seven nine two five
five two toll-free if you've tried to
call us before and got in the busy
signal now's the time to get on board
because we got tough empty lines for you
at eight three one six eight five 1080
or triple eight three seven nine two
five five two if you have questions
about the in jeopardy products um Javits
e-business a health challenge you or a
loved one may be dealing with or if you
just have a success story like to share
if you just want to contribute to the
conversation eight three one six eight
five ten eighty is your priority line
number triple eight three seven nine two
five five two toll-free I am pharmacist
Ben nutritional pharmacist from Boulder
Colorado I use nutritional supplements
where other health care practitioners
use toxic pharmaceutical drugs that's
because I look at the human body as a
healing system or regenerating system
designed divinely to heal and renew
itself on a moment-to-moment basis no
doctors required no drugs required just
good nutrition a good diet a little bit
exercise and a lot of good a lot of long
luscious rest that's pretty much all
health is about I call it the fourfold
square of health nutri eight respirate
move and rest and there is no room for a
doctor in the equation unless of course
you have some kind of emergency
procedure I call that heroic man
I have a need for heroic medicine well
then you need a doctor but when it comes
to maintaining our bodies on a day to
day basis that's the job a good
nutrition and good living
I pharmacist panicked of three one six
eight five ten eighty eight three one
six eight five ten eighty is our
priority line number triple eight three
seven nine two five five two toll-free
we do have lines open for you so as we
come into coffin cold season coffin cold
and flu season you're gonna hear lots
about the flu vaccines we're gonna be
bombarded with advertisements and
warnings and admonitions to make sure
we're vaccinated against the flu the
Centers for Disease Control tells us
that getting an annual flu vaccine is
the best way to protect yourself from
the flu I beg to differ as a farm
assistant as somebody who's studied
medicine for thirty years thirty plus
years literally medicine drug medicine
for thirty going on 32 or 33 years I
stay as far away as I can from the flu
vaccine I recommend you do too you do as
well the best way to protect yourself
from the flu is not the flu vaccine it's
to make sure you're taking care of
yourself it's make sure you're staying
away from processed foods make sure
you're staying away from sugar as best
as you can
exercising resting the 4-fold square of
health nutri eight respirate move and
rest and of course making sure that you
get on a good nutritional supplement
program if you do get sick a healthy
body can recover from the flu pretty
darn easily within a couple of days for
most of us it's not a life-threatening
issue it's certainly nothing that you
need to be vaccinated for you could also
try to drink fresh pineapple juice or
eat fresh pineapple according to
research from the natural society
published last week in the lake chelan
mirror that's Lake Chelan Washington
using fresh pineapple juice to treat
sore throats and cost is up to five
times more effective than any coffee
that you'll find in a drugstore or any
any place not just a drugstore but any
place supermarkets where you buy your
wherever you buy your coffee and cold
preparations fight pineapples are packed
with flu busting nutrients vitamin C B
complex zinc manganese and pineapples
are also a great source of something
called bromelain bromelain is an enzyme
and according to the natural society
website
bromelain pineapple enzyme fights
inflammation
which soothe irritated Airways and has
antiviral properties anti-inflammatory
properties and antibacterial properties
all which synergistically soothe sore
throats and help relieve coughs relaxing
the bronchial Airways and at the same
time fighting infections bromelain is a
digestive enzyme if you look on your
ultimate enzymes on the side you'll see
bromelain everyone knows the digestive
enzymes help us digest our food and
assimilate what we eat but as it turns
out these really multifunctional and
versatile natural molecules have
multiple health benefits in addition to
helping soothe sore throats and
alleviating dry cost digestive enzymes
also have wonderful anti-inflammatory
properties that you can use to reduce
pain sinus pain headache pain dental
pain back pain you gotta take them on an
empty stomach if you want to leverage
their anti-inflammatory properties
though their their digestive enzymes
when you're taking with food but their
systemic enzymes they go into the body
system when you take them on an empty
stomach and when you take them on an
empty stomach they do some really cool
things a lot of times the pain that we
that we suffer from whether it's
migraine pain or the pain of a wound or
some kind of trauma a lot of times the
result the pain is the result of the
accumulation of protein clots and fibers
as well as immune cell complexes and
fluids systemic enzymes that is
digestive enzymes when you take them on
an empty stomach can bust open these
clogs and improve healing times and
minimize swelling and minimize
inflammation and this is really
important for folks who are going into a
surgical procedure both before surgery
and when you're recovering from surgery
if you take digestive enzyme supplements
your ultimate enzymes from youngevity on
an empty stomach for maybe two weeks or
so before surgery and then a couple two
three four weeks after surgery you're
gonna find that not only are you healing
much quicker much more quickly but
you'll also find that you have much less
post-surgical pain and much less post
surgical bruising it's all from plain
old digestive enzymes your two main
digestive enzymes are going to be found
in pineapple and also in papaya
pineapple is called bromelain as we've
said in papaya they're called papain and
these are the most important or the most
commonly found digestive enzymes for
busting through protein
they call proteases because they bust
through proteins you'll also find a
digestive enzymes in your bio luminite
Lee essence this is one of the reasons
why I talk about this product all the
time the by lumen nightly essence is a
wonderful source of probiotics good
bacteria for intestinal health it's got
quite a wide range of different bacteria
it's got a lot of bacteria it's a big ol
dose of probiotics but in addition to
the 14 different strains of bacteria
you also get digestive enzymes and that
is very unusual in the world of
probiotics probiotics plus digestive
enzymes can duo have wonderfully
beneficial effects on on the digestive
process and you find that in your
nightly essence long story short folks
you don't need a flu vaccine get on a
good nutritional supplement program if
you have problems with your digestion
use your ultimate enzymes and your
bioluminescence and if you're dealing
with inflammation or any kind of pain
issue or post pre or post surgery use
your ultimate enzymes on an empty
stomach
I'm pharmacist Pam you're listening to
the dead doctors don't lie program eight
three one six eight five ten 80s on
priority line number triple eight three
seven nine two five five two toll free
we'll be back right after this
[Music]
in recent years several studies have
discovered the healthy benefits of
drinking coffee youngevity has now taken
it a step further with an entire product
line of healthy coffees from youngevity
java fit selection of top shelf gourmet
coffees all java fit coffees are made
from 100% premium hand selected a rack
of a coffee beans grown in the finest
regions of Latin America carefully
roasted creating a delicious rich
full-bodied flavor try Java fits
original roast a perfect blend of mellow
and smooth with just the right
full-bodied depth to make an aromatic
and enjoyable cup of coffee traditional
as well as organic and fair trade
options also available in 30 Cal single
cup or 24 count single pot packs contact
your local FDI youngevity distributor to
get java lucien coffees and don't forget
to ask about home-based business
opportunities hello Judy Deville vez
here if I could only afford to get one
product out of everything that product
would be the ultimate classic it has the
vitamins the minerals the bio flavonoids
it even has grapeseed extract the one
product that would give you just about
everything under the Sun you would need
for a perfect nutritional program would
be the ultimate classic by the way
people that are on the go it's very very
hard to take the liquids with them when
they go on their trip to get their
supplements in everyday well you know
something you can use the ultimate daily
tablets and the mineral capsules when
I'm going on a trip if I have enough
room I just take the two bottles with me
if not just use a little baggie and take
a couple of daily doses with you it's
very simple it's very easy there's no
mess no fuss no refrigeration just take
your capsules take your tablets and
you're finished for the day
to order these products call your local
youngevity distributor today
[Music]
okay we're back on the dead doctors
don't wipe rogram I am pharmacist been
sitting in for dr. Wallach today thanks
for joining us got lines open
forty-eight three one six eight five ten
eighty eight three one six eight five
ten eighty that's our priority line
number triple a three seven nine two
five five to toll-free if you have
questions about the youngevity products
or the youngevity business if you want
to wean yourself off your medication and
get on a good nutritional supplement
program like the one formulated by dr.
Wallach we can help you do that and if
you are on a chronic prescription drug
or you're chronically taking a
prescription drug I should say your
number one health challenge should be to
figure out how to get yourself off that
drug you are not doing your body any
good ever by taking a prescription drug
do you sometimes need prescription drugs
well yes sometimes you need an
antibiotic sometimes you need a pain
pill you may need to be managed with
some kind of antihypertensive in the
short very very short term but if you're
on a drug now your number one health
challenge to be to figure out how to
wean yourself off of it because you're
burdening your body you're amplifying
and enhancing the effects of nutritional
deficiencies people don't talk about
that you know when you take a
prescription drug your body uses vitamin
C to detoxify itself from that drug that
means you were running high risks of
being deficient in vitamin C your body
uses the B complex to purify itself from
the prescription drugs you're right high
risks of taking the because of
deficiencies in the B complex your body
is burning through zinc it's burning
through manganese it's burning through
magnesium it's burning through copper
with every statin drug you take with
every antihypertensive drug you take
with every serotonin reuptake inhibitor
you take with every birth control pill
you take you are running higher risks
for nutritional deficiencies and the
diseases and health challenges that are
caused by those nutritional deficiencies
that's why it's so darn important to get
yourself on a supplement program to wean
yourself off your meds to practice the
fourfold square of health to leverage
the body's god-given healing abilities
which we witness every time we cut
ourselves and watch that little cut heal
itself all by itself
all right eight three one six eight five
ten eighty is our priority line number
laid three seven nine two five five two
toll-free I am pharmacist been sitting
in for doc Wallach along with my good
friend and colleague Douglas Winfrey
what's up Doug well when I saw this
story on Fox News I thought immediately
of you and welcome to the show you
haven't been out in a while so it's been
me I sure did yeah I appreciate that
and what they're talking about is
something called water fasting and
they're talking about this before that
worse diets to come down the pike in
fact the headline reads water fasting
isn't a diet it's a starvation experts
warn where'd you read that where is that
fours on fox news they say water fasting
is which you consume nothing but water
for several days or weeks at a time
that's not a diet it's starvation they
say the intermittent fasting regimes in
which dieters commit to extended number
of hours without food specific regimen
win which is scientifically proven to
have a number of metabolic effects
prolonged starvation regimes offer no
such benefits they say because water
contains no calories or vitamins and
very low in minerals in a short period
in which no calories are consumed 24
hours or less can see dieters are
reunited with their natural hunger and
enjoying an initial drop of the scales
as the body's fuel stores are used
success is short-lived after initial 24
to 48 hours of no calories not only are
the fuel stores of glycogen in the
muscles depleted but over a time
metabolic rate will slow to help manage
the fuel storage this is why dieters may
describe feeling light and euphoric
initially but over time the effect is
replaced with fatigue hunger and
inability to concentrate in general
lethargy so but you'll often talk about
you know that fasting but regular time
yeah you're not talking about weeks
no I was gonna ask you though when you
recommend fasting would you recommend
that people continue to do their
alliance yeah that's a great question
uh you know if you don't do the 90 for
life for one or two days it's not gonna
be the end of the world if you do take
the 90 if you do do the 90 for life it's
not gonna ruin your fast remember when
you're fasting you're trying to not not
eliminate nutrition you're try to
eliminate calories there's no calories
and
94 life so it doesn't take a lot of work
for the body to process so either way it
could go either way one or two days of
missing your supplements isn't going to
be the end of the world and if you do
take your mighty 90 essential nutrients
it's not gonna ruin the fast I noticed
that the fox news story doesn't talk
about a one day water fast or two day
water fast though do they know they do I
think that's the Trib though is it to go
for several days several days is you
know that's kind of a vague term several
I would say one or two maybe three days
but here's another thing if you put a
little celery in your water in your
water fast and I'm not talking about
celery juice but actually just kind of
drop chopping up celery and letting it
sit in the water do you ever see how
they do that in hotels sometimes I'll
slice cucumbers and they'll put them in
water or they'll
or they'll drop sliced strawberries or
something in water it's quite delicious
actually but not only is it delicious
but it's slicing up fruit fruits or
veggies and putting it in water -
something else for you and I'll tell you
what that is when we come back from our
break
I am pharmacist been sitting in for dr.
Wallach today along with Doug Winfrey
and you and your phone calls await 3 1 6
8 5 10 80 or triple 8 3 7 9 to 5 5 to
toll-free you're listening to the dead
doctors don't lie radio program we'll be
back right after this
[Music]
imagine a rich decadent chocolate that's
actually good for you young Gemma DS
triple treat chocolate is just that an
antioxidant rich dark chocolate complete
with probiotics to aid in proper
digestion this all-natural product
contains no preservatives and for those
with dietary restrictions its
gluten-free dairy-free glycemic friendly
and kosher certified not only does
triple treat dark chocolate taste
fantastic
it contains super antioxidant
blueberries to absorb free radicals with
an ORAC value of sixteen thousand nine
hundred and thirty six per piece triple
treat chocolate also contains a
proprietary blend of probiotics with
over 500 million live healthy bacteria
per eight grams at the time of
manufacture with eighty percent reaching
the intestines which is much more than
most live culture yogurts if you'd like
to learn more about nutritional
supplementation call your local
youngevity associate and don't forget to
ask about home-based business
opportunities hi everyone Andy Anderson
here are you using those handy little
bottles of gel that zap germs bacteria
and other nasties in today's world
that's smart especially with all the
filthy doorknobs shopping carts and
handrails we touch every day here's what
you may not know once the alcohol
evaporates
goodbye effectiveness no more protection
until you use it again pure works to the
rescue our FDA compliant foam lotion
soap and spray do not rely on alcohol
their killing power lasts up to four
hours pure work disinfecting spray is
EPA certified to kill swine flu bird flu
MRSA HIV hepatitis B and C in a whole
host of viruses and bacteria mold and
fungus too it's even safe around
children and pets
you'll love the soft feel a pure works
on your hand it actually conditions that
will not dry your skin here's a little
peace of mind knowing your hands are
still germ-free hours later get your
hands on peer works and get pure works
on your hands stand by pull out your
paper and pencil for your local number
to order pure works you've listed to
physician and veterinarian dr. Joel
Wallach helped many people all the dead
doctors don't lie talk radio program
you've also heard hundreds of people
tell how dr. Wallach and youngevity
products have changed their lives if
you're now convinced that dr. Wallach is
on
something and you want to try your
Japanese premium quality products for
yourself we could connect you with the
distributor that serves your local area
simply call our special helpline
voicemail at three one three four 44 34
63 that's three one three four four four
three four six three call right now and
leave your name telephone number or
email address and we'll see to it that
the right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call down to change your life
that's three one three four four four
[Music]
we're back on the doctors don't lie
program I am pharmacist and along with
Doug Winfrey sitting in for dr. Wallach
today and taking your phone calls and we
do have lines open for you at eight
three one six a five ten eighty eight
three one six eight five ten eighty or
triple a three seven nine two five five
two toll-free if you have questions or
comments about the youngevity products
or youngevity business or success
stories you'd like to share with us or
if you just want to contribute to the
conversation we do have lines open eight
three one six eight five ten eighty or
triple eight three seven nine two five
five two toll-free I am pharmacist Ben
nutritional pharmacist I used nutrients
instead of drugs a practice pharmacy
with nutrition because good nutrition as
I like to say good nutrition is good
medicine before I went to the break were
time out water fasts I'm a big believer
in fasting as you know Doug I've been
talking about it for years I practice
what's called intermittent fasting
myself were you fast
one day a month or two days a month just
kind of when you feel like doing it I
fast every day yeah between meals or
something I have a breakfast of the 40th
at I don't eat again for about 12 to 14
hours actually that's you know I don't
know if you're kidding or not but I
rarely eat lunch it's a great strategy
you're generating ketones during that
during that 12 hour period when you're
not eating so the less you eat the
longer you live because food represents
work do you need to eat obviously I'm
not saying don't eat but it
still work you're expending nutritional
resources you're expending energy just
to digest your food now under under good
circumstances or ideal circumstances
when you eat food you replace the
nutrients you're expending in the
digestive process by the foods you're
eating unfortunately most of the foods
we don't have nutrients in them and this
is why supplement program is so darn
important if you're going to be fasting
if you're going to practice a water fast
one or two days without supplements
isn't gonna hurt you but if you really
if you want to get a little bit of maybe
some vitamins or some minerals in your
system put it a little bit of beyond
tangy tangerine in your water when
you're drinking it and you'll get your
nutrient you'll get a little bit of your
nutrients you probably won't get as many
as much as if you do a full supplement
program but you'll get enough to get you
through and you'll have some energy you
can also slice up cucumbers and slice up
strawberries these provide wonderful
wonderful natural plant nutrients and
you don't want to underestimate the
power of these plant nutrients are so
called phyto nutrients phytonutrients
are found throughout the plant kingdom
especially berries as it turns out
berries are your best source of
phytonutrients the only problem with
berries strawberries and blueberries and
raspberries etc only probably
blueberries and and berries in general
is they are so tiny they tend to absorb
a lot of pesticides so you always want
to go organic if you can with your
berries even if you're out of season
even if when even when they're out of
season you can get great berries in your
frozen food section
and they make great little candies
berries do you can suck on them like a
little candy and get a little bit of
sweetness of course you'll get your
phytonutrients your plant nutrients and
your pigments reading just reading this
article here this is from the Center for
Disease Control came out just just today
berries give a boost to cervical cancer
therapy according to the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention
approximately 12,000 women in the United
States diagnosed with cervical cancer
and who are treated with cervical cancer
apparently a blueberry extract combined
with radiation increased the treatments
effectiveness after you get better
results when you use berries or when you
enjoy berries with your chemo therapy of
course you don't have to be undergoing
chemotherapy to benefit from berries
berries are wonderful sources of
resveratrol all
so good sources of vitamin C and other
phytonutrients and berries are great for
your skin so as you're enjoying your
strawberries or your blueberries or your
raspberries whether as a candy or sliced
up on top of nuts that's how I like to
do my berries just sliced up on top of
of almonds personally crush up almonds
and slice them up and slice up some
berries and stir it in together it's
really add a little bit of honey if you
want some sweetness super delicious not
only will you be protecting yourself
from cancers and colds and coughs and
colds not only will slicing berries up
into water help you go through a water
fast but they're also wonderful for
protecting your skin from the Sun all
right I'm pharmacist penny a three one
six eight five ten eighty is our
priority line number triple eight three
seven nine two five five two toll-free
if you've got questions about the mjv
products or youngevity business comments
or success stories like to share we're
here for you we'll take a commercial
break and come back with more good
health information and your phone calls
and the dead doctors don't lie radio
program
[Music]
you've listed a position dad
veterinarian dr. Joel Wallach helped
many people on the dead doctors don't
lie talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how dr. Wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
dr. Wallach is on to something and you
want to try your Japanese premium
quality products for yourself we can
connect you with a distributor that
serves your local area simply call our
special helpline voicemail at three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call right now and leave your name
telephone number or email address
and we'll see to it that the right
person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call down to change your life
that's three one three four four four
hi this dr. Joel Wallach your host of
dead doctors don't lie if you're
interested in a colon cleanse blood
cleanse liver cleanse you know in the
classical herbal way you want to ask
your youngevity associate for herbal
rainforest herbal rain forest has 16
herbs 16 cleansing herbs classic
cleansing herbs and 77 plant minerals
that's right and these are all organic
it doesn't get any better than that
and your busy day and you're around all
these toxins out there in your workplace
on the way home going to work in your
food in the air in the water you need
herbal rainforest I guarantee it
it will give you a cleanse you can
control the dose it's a liquid it tastes
good it doesn't get any better than this
a colon that's happy makes you happy
nothing better than a happy :
herbal rainforest clean it out for more
information on this product or others
you've heard about all the dead doctors
don't lie radio program call your local
youngevity associate today and don't
forget to ask about home-based business
opportunities greetings everyone
Judy developers here what do you think
of when you hear the words tangy
tangerine well I think of like a sweet
tangy tasting something well what I'm
referring to is the ultimate tangy
tangerine
it's a fantastic product it has
everything you need and a great benefit
is it's very very delicious it's very
easy to drink I've suggested it even to
youngsters even children like even
little guys even little girls they come
right into my office their parents can't
get them to take those chewables and
besides that they're not as good as
tangy tangerine and I give them a little
taste of that and you know something
they're pleased as punch so if it's good
for a child and it tastes delicious why
not you there's no excuse not to take a
vitamin when it tastes as good as that
does so how about it tangy tangerine
should be the answer to all of your
nutritional program problems for more
information or to order call your
youngevity distributor today and don't
forget to ask about youngevity
home-based business opportunities this
is the CBS Radio Network Network
[Music]
don't lie radio program I in pharmacist
been sitting in for doc today along with
Doug Winfrey and you and your phone
calls it eight three one six eight five
ten eighty eight three one six
eighty-five 1080 or triple eight three
seven nine two five five two toll-free
if you have questions about anything
we're speaking about here today if you
have a health challenge that you or a
loved one is dealing with if you want to
wean yourself off your meds and get on a
good nutritional supplement program we
can help you eight three one six eight
five ten eighty is our priority line
number triple a three seven nine two
five five two toll-free got lines open
for you and it is time to hit the phones
who's first in line up all right let's
head to Houston Texas and Paul you're on
with pharmacist Ben Fuchs
hey Paul how are you I'm good what's
going on in Houston Texas well I'm
calling how long did you have the flu
just I don't mean to interrupt you but
how long did you have the flu it was a
24 hour Connie 24 hour kind of thing two
days of just sleeping it off but my
brother got me on vitamin C mega doses
are you doing the youngevity products no
I just he then turned me on to these as
well he's so I've only known about for
about are you kidding where have you
been where have you been hiding yourself
Paul problem so so one of the questions
I had been are you available for
consultation yeah I do all kinds of
consultations a couple things you could
do and this is for anybody listening
who's interested in having me help you
out you can send me an email
ven-ven at KSC Oh calm send an email put
your phone number there if you don't put
your phone number it's very difficult
for me to respond everybody
email but I can call you make sure you
put your phone um in there and I'll give
me a few days and I'll get ahold of you
by phone and we'll have a conversation
I'm happy to help you out you can also
listen to my radio program which is
called the bright side it's on every day
on this on the Genesis communication
network and we also have six years plus
of archived information and we go over
all kinds of stuff much like this
program we go over all kinds of health
information then we take phone calls so
I'm happy to help you out that way as
well but if you have questions now
what's going on shooting maybe we can
help you here
well yeah my girlfriend need to get on
the product I was declared totally
disabled via bipolar in 1993 oh my
goodness that's when they first came out
with that diagnosis by the way right
around there you saw manic depressive
disorder you remember that history but
so to make a long story short I'm 64 now
I've been sober for 24 years nice and
well there's your problem my friend we
got we start you got to start working
out digest let me tell you how I work
cuz you're new at that you you're new to
my message here so let me tell you how I
like to work I always consider the
digestive system to be the core of
everything after the digestive system
starts to break down the blood sugar
system takes over the blood sugar system
gets begins to break down as well
because you're not handling energy as
efficiently long story short and so then
you run into problems with obesity and
and and high blood pressure
cardiovascular issues etc blood sugar
issues too and then you've once the
blood I jest of system and the blood
sugar system are thrown off or out of
whack if you will then you start running
into problems with your stress
management system and your thyroid and
from there all diseases ensue so I call
that the triangle of disease the
digestive system the blood sugar system
and the adrenal thyroid complex and I
can guarantee you my friend just from
talking to you for a couple minutes here
that not only is your digestive system
thrown off but you also got blood sugar
problems and you're probably a diabetic
even if you're not diagnosed as such
your blood Sugar's thrown off so you
might as well be diagnosed as a diabetic
you're probably hypothyroid too so we're
gonna help you out though that's the bad
news but we're gonna help you out so
don't go away Paul okay got to take a
commercial break we'll come back with
Paul finish up and then we'll take you
as well if you're on hold and we do have
lines open at 8:30 one six eight five
ten eighty four triple eight three seven
nine two five five two on pharmacist
been sitting in for dr. Wallach today
you're listening to the dead doctors
don't lie radio program we'll be back
right after this
[Music]
[Applause]
you've listed a physician dad
veterinarian dr. Joel Wallach helped
many people on the dead doctors don't
lie talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how dr. Wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
dr. Wallach is on to something and you
want to try your Japanese premium
quality products for yourself we can
connect you with a distributor that
serves your local area simply call our
special helpline voicemail at three one
three four four four 3463
that's three one three four four four
three four six three call right now and
leave your name telephone number or
email address and we'll see to it that
the right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number three one
three four four four 3463
that's three one three four four four
three four six three call down to change
your life that's three one three four
four four 3463 I am Judy de valois here
I am speaking to you again
I just wanted to tell you that recently
I started drinking the way shakes again
the chocolate way shake and you need to
remember the way shake isn't just for
losing weight it's a fantastic place to
get your great protein and if you're
trying to gain weight you can take it
along with your meals and the best part
is if you want to just have a great
protein shake do like I do put it over
ice stir it up and you can sip on it for
twenty minutes to an hour I'd do it
every single day I absolutely love it
you need to get back to it too it's
really good for you and it makes not fat
but it makes muscle after you workout
and you can also mix it up in a blender
with an egg and you have the most
incredible health protein shake or mix
it with a little water stir it up and
you have a little pudding and who
doesn't like puddin for more information
or to order call your youngevity
distributor today and don't forget to
ask about youngevity home-based business
opportunities
[Music]
[Applause]
okay we're back on the doctors don't lie
program I'm farm spin and we have lines
open for you at eight three one six
eight five ten eighty or triple eight
three seven nine two five five two
toll-free I'm talking to Paul in Houston
Texas are you there Paul yes okay so
we're gonna fix you right out first of
all just understand that the more broken
down the body is the faster it recovers
that's the good news your body can
recover really really fast now not a
hundred percent but the recovery process
can begin
almost instantly almost as soon as you
make a decision really that's when the
bots the recovery process begins once
you get on a supplement program you're
gonna start to notice dramatic results
so you said you lost some your colon you
got some have any history of
diverticulitis tell me about the are you
diagnosed as a diabetic or do you have
any blood sugar issues or do you have
weight issues or blood pressure issues
anything like that yeah okay yeah your
your blood Sugar's off your blood
Sugar's off and your thyroid is probably
off too yes go ahead
you know growing up I never had sugar
cravings I have tremendous sure sugar
cravings all the time to get work well
let me tell you the mechanism here you
sound like a bright guy here someone
tell you exactly what's happening when
your body is low in sugar you're gonna
go out and crave sugar then you go and
eat some sugar and all of a sudden your
blood sugar concentration gets higher
and the body doesn't like a high blood
sugar concentration so insulin will come
out to the rescue almost like the fire
department putting out a fire it'll pull
that sugar out of your blood and you're
gonna crave sugar and then you go get
some sugar and the whole process begins
it begins again to make matters worse
once insulin levels go up you tend to
gain weight so between your cravings for
sugar and your elevated insulin and your
problems getting energy because of your
loss you don't have a colon you're you
got a really focus big-time on how
you're eating and how you're
supplementing first things first you got
to stay away from any foods that make
you feel uncomfortable and by
uncomfortable I'm saying I mean things
like diarrhea constipation gas bloating
just a feeling of pressure in the
stomach anything that messes up your
digestive system or makes you feel
comfortable in your digestive system you
got to stay away from that got a zero
tolerance for that kind of food the
second thing you want to do is you want
to make sure that you're using nutrients
that help your supplements I should say
that help your body process food chief
of which are the good bacteria or the
probiotics now with diverticulitis
you're at high risk for what's known as
dysbiosis
that means messed up gut bacteria you
should not wait one moment soon as you
hang up the phone get yourself some
nightly essence from youngevity call
your youngevity rep or get on the
youngevity website and order the nightly
essence and start taking nine capsules a
day three capsules three times a day you
may need even a little bit more than
that
with your history of digestive issues
but start off with three capsules three
times a day and maybe bump it up to four
three times a day for a couple weeks if
you notice that you get benefits that
way another thing you could do is make
sure you're using the ultimate enzymes
with apple cider vinegar with all of
your meals the digest event the ultimate
enzymes contain digestive enzymes that
help you process foods so that they're
sort of pre digested or pre broken down
before they hit the intestine keeping in
mind that you've lost some of your
intestine so anything you do to
pre-process your foods effectively in
the stomach will help you absorb
nutrients later on down the road in your
intestine as the food goes down the goes
down the pipe so to speak eating less
food is very important for you and what
you eat you should try to grind up or
blend you know in a Vitamix or some kind
of smoothie making device a blender of
some kind your favorite food your best
food Paul should be chicken soup
homemade chicken soup not Campbell's
chicken soup but homemade chicken soup
homemade chicken soup contains wonderful
cartilage factors that can help you
strengthen your digestive system help
build a strong intestine which you have
left of your intestine also has benefits
for your immune system and it's also
very filling and it's a great source of
liquid protein because of your digestive
impairment you're at very high risk for
protein deficiencies and that just means
you're not going to build and you're not
going to grow and repair but using
homemade chicken soup can be a great way
to get liquid protein also you might
want to try our Kido EFX smoothies and
slender FX smoothies as well those are
also good sources of liquid protein and
I'll be using the beyond tangy tangerine
every day
but go slowly on the beyond tangy
tangerine maybe a teaspoon in water half
a teaspoon in water and then sip on it
throughout the day you don't want to too
big a dose with what seems how you're
missing some intestine you might get a
little bit of loose stool or diarrhea if
you do too much of the beyond tangy
tangerine Healthy Start pack will be
great for you as well that's got all
your mighty 90 essential nutrients so
got lots of stuff that you can work on
there's tons more Paul just know that
the more broken down your body is the
faster you turn it around begin to turn
it around you can you could be a new man
in seven days and you can certainly
notice some significant differences in
24 to 48 48 hours if you do everything
we said here on this program okay
appreciate your call Paul thanks so much
for listening and thanks for being a new
listener and a new member of our
youngevity family appreciate it okay 831
685 1080 is our priority line number
triple 8 3 7 9 2 5 5 2 toll-free who's
next in line does all right let's head
to Bellingham Washington and Michael
you're on with pharmacist Ben Fuchs hey
Michael hello what's going on buddy ok I
hear you loud and God god bless you my
friend what's going on how can we help
you I'm badly I'm calling for me and my
wife I'm battling high blood pressure
and I've been doctoring and the drugs
don't work they've done a lot of tests
on me like ultrasounds and echoes and
stuff like that literally found nothing
wrong they're using your ATM machine
that's what doc says they're using you
for an ATM machine
chi-ching why there's no there's no more
money left ok then they're gonna throw
you out but and while you have some
money I love seeing you walk in there
because you represent LTM machine
you represent somebody's mortgage
payment and somebody's car payment
that's not fair
I appreciate and we're gonna help you
yeah but check this out Paul you said
Paul right Paul Paul is that your name
Michael or I'm sorry Michael Michael I'm
sorry Michael so here's the deal Michael
what if you went to a plumber or you
what if your toilet was clogged and the
plumber came over and he said you know I
can't do anything for your toilet but
I'm gonna come back once a month and
you're gonna pay me and I'm just gonna
check to see just to look in the toilet
once a month what
think or what have you brought your car
to a mechanic and the mechanics that you
know Paul Michael I can't do anything
for your car but you got to come back
and see me once a month so just so I can
take a look at what I can't do any or
what I can't fix you'd say you know what
the heck are you talking about I'm not
going back to you but we do it with
doctors for some reason we go back and
we go back and we back and they don't do
anything for us and as I was talking
about earlier more often than not we're
just gonna get sicker because the drugs
that they give us the so-called
treatments that they give us put more of
a burden on the body and this tragic
thing it's terrible especially with the
drugs they've been giving you the the
drugs they give you for blood pressure
are among the most deadly and toxic of
all the drugs in the United States
pharmacopoeia the USP the formulary all
of the drugs the thousands of drugs that
they're available the blood pressure
drugs are among the most toxic they call
them beta blockers and calcium channel
blockers but even the diuretics are
problematic as well all the drugs they
give you for blood pressure control are
especially toxic you know why because
the body doesn't want to have its blood
pressure monkeyed around with the body
is very tightly controlled when it comes
to how the blood pressure moves if it's
high it's high for a reason and you
can't poison your way back to health
it's not possible so what you want to do
if you have high blood pressures you
want to regard it as a sign of a body in
duress we got to learn to speak body
we've got to learn to speak biology we
got to learn to speak the language of
biochemistry the language of the body
body's always talking to us but the
words it uses are symptoms we call
symptoms are just the language of the
bodies there's the body talking to us
high blood pressure says help me I'm in
duress I'm in distress please help me
that's what high blood pressure says to
somebody who speaks body that's a sign a
cry for help it means something is
burdening the body and you can tell this
you know we we have this up you know
there's kind of people make jokes about
how you know your mother-in-law make
your blood pressure go up I don't want
to pick on mothers in law but you know
little things in our life we say oh that
made my blood pressure go up why because
stress makes your blood pressure go up
that doesn't have to be psychological
stress it doesn't have to be emotional
distress
can be the stress of sugar it can be the
stress of the wrong kind of food it can
be the stress of some kind of
inflammatory process that's happening in
the body and it can be the stress
associated with dirty toxic blood and
it's very easy to resolve this in fact
don't go away Michael we're gonna finish
up when we come back from break I'm
gonna tell you a easy way to drop your
blood pressure in minutes and a
beautiful comfortable way non-toxic way
that will not only lower your blood
pressure but add years to your life
we'll talk about that when we come back
from our break on the dead doctors don't
lie radio program I'm pharmacist Bend
along with Doug Winfrey city improvement
doctor wallet today got lines open eight
three one six eight five ten eighty or
triple eight three seven nine two five
five two toll-free we'll be back right
after this
[Music]
many believe that all life began in the
Earth's oceans we do know that the
oceans and seas are still abundant with
life and life-sustaining nutrients many
cultures have long believed in the
life-giving properties of plants and sea
life harvested from the oceans young
Japanese oceans gold is a proprietary
blend of seaweeds algie's losses kelp
sea cucumbers and sea minerals as well
as coenzyme q-10 calcium and iron all
designed to help support healthy thyroid
function regular heartbeat normal weight
mood stabilization and hormone levels
take advantage of life-sustaining
nutrients from the Earth's oceans with
youngevity oceans gold if you'd like to
learn more about nutritional
supplementation call your local
youngevity associate and don't forget to
ask about home-based business
opportunities hey if you're like me your
life is hectic you don't know where
you're gonna be next between kids and
family and in-laws
and work and traffic and everything else
that's driving me crazy right now
my life is insane I bet your life's
insane as well when do we have time to
get every single nutrient we need to be
healthy when well I've got a tip for you
take a product called pollen burst it's
so simple even I can do it all you have
to do is open the package pour it in
water mix it up and bam you're ready to
go it tastes great it's not one of those
medicine tasting things it tastes great
low in calories helps curb your appetite
gives you natural energy that doesn't
let you crash gives you your vitamins
minerals nutrients everything from the
plant world and I gotta tell you for a
busy person like me or a busy person
like you we need simple we need good
poem verses your answer tastes great try
it and you'll feel better call your
local youngevity distributor to find out
how pollen burst can make you feel
better
ahead don't forget to ask about
home-based business opportunities you've
listened to physician and veterinarian
dr. Joel Wallach helped many people on
the dead doctors don't lie talk radio
program you've also heard hundreds of
people tell how dr. Wallach and
youngevity products
have changed their lives if you're now
convinced that dr. Wallach is on to
something and you want to try your
Japanese premium quality products for
yourself we could connect you with a
distributor that serves your local area
simply call our special helpline
voicemail at three one three four four
four 3463
that's three one three four four four
three four six three call right now and
leave your name telephone number or
email address and we'll see to it that
the right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call down to change your life
that's three one three four four four
3463 okay we're back on the dead doctors
don't lie program pharmacist Ben and
Doug Winfrey sitting in for doc today
talking to Michael are you there my
friend Michael I am
hey Michael are you in Washington I'm
like to add a few things I've had I
ended up in the hospital here about a
year ago because of high blood pressure
my numbers were like 250 over 180 ain't
good I mean some Smith Stein I know and
the only thing they said my kidneys were
elevated get that blood pressure
yeah yeah well you don't need to you
don't need to Michael I know you're
falling apart dude you don't need to
tell me about the protein of the kidneys
because that's just they call that in
medicine sequelae seq ula e that means
things that happen they're secondary
secondary to the blood pressure all
kinds of things can go wrong you don't
need to share the grim details but I'm
gonna tell you I saw the problem okay
you've gotta relax the body number one
you've got to eliminate any toxicity and
that includes sugar that's getting into
the body number two and you got to get
on a nutritional supplement program
number three so let's start those are
the three steps okay first things first
relax the body as much as possible and
you can observe the the the
antihypertensive effects of relaxation
by sitting in a hot bath just sitting in
a hot bath my friend will lower your
blood pressure faster and
in a more non-toxic fashion than than
any prescription drug you can get from
the doctor not a hot bath but a warm
bath a comfortable bath or a warm shower
for that matter slow deep breathing I
call it SDR breathing slow deep rhythmic
breathing can also have a dramatically a
dramatic effect on lowering your blood
pressure again more effective than any
drug you can take and non-toxic and then
the second point in the back you've the
relaxation stages or steps the second
part of the puzzle is to eliminate
toxicity that's getting into the body
that means food toxicity mostly unless
you're off in the back alley injecting
cracking through your arm most of us the
toxicity is gonna be food-related
that means eliminating any problem foods
and strengthening the digestive system
with your ultimate enzymes and your
nightly essence probiotics also some
apple cider vinegar with your meals the
less food you eat also the better off
you'll be from a blood pressure
perspective just eating salads can raise
your blood pressure sometimes if you're
having an issue with specific foods
eliminating any foods that mess up your
digestive system can be very important
and go low sugar go ketogenic if you can
that means a low sugar diet sugar spikes
your blood pressure and also high blood
pressure and blood sugar problems go
hand-in-hand almost guaranteed you've
got some blood sugar problems with that
kind of blood pressure and then the
third part of the puzzle is get yourself
on the mighty 90 essential nutrients
that is the healthy start pack that
beyond tangy tangerine you want to throw
in the ultimate IFAs which will help
lower your blood pressure the beyond
osteo FX has magnesium which is
wonderfully antihypertensive it's
nature's calcium channel blocker the
beyond osteo effects and the magnesium
is I should say and then the ultimate
niacin which is a timed release dose of
niacin is wonderful for helping you
lower your blood pressure I would also
personally be throwing in the few coins
II and the ultimate selenium - both are
important for the heart the
cardiovascular system and also may have
a antihypertensive effect it's got lots
of things you could do my friend
none of them involve a doctor none of
them are toxic you're not gonna have to
stand in line at the pharmacy in
addition to not dealing with
side-effects and toxicity you're
actually gonna be adding years to your
life
thanks for call Michael appreciate or
you had one more question I think
Michael did you have one more for us
yeah
yes sir yeah I am on I am on the 90
essential minerals from dr. from
youngevity and my and my wife said that
when she takes him she gets nauseous and
tired and I smaller doses smaller doses
she's probably taking too much her body
can't handle it and that'll cause a
little bit of I can see a little bit of
non nausea but I don't know I
the tired I would not attribute to the
supplement supplements aren't going to
make you tired but smaller doses is your
solution to that any time you're having
some diarrhea or loose stools or
constipation or upset stomach from the
supplements you always want a smaller
dose sometimes you have to work yourself
up into the standard dose because if
you're not used to your body's not used
to a high dose of nutrition it could be
a little bit hard on the body to put a
whole bunch in all at once so smaller
doses divided doses divided doses in
general are always the way to go thanks
for calling Michael appreciate it god
bless you my friend let's see if we get
one more call in Doug before a break oh
we've only got about 20 seconds oh
that's too bad I'm sorry I tried to get
everybody and got a call and early on
the dead doctors don't lie program so we
can get to as many calls as possible if
you're on the fence about a nutritional
supplement program please my friends
give it a shot if you're on medication
it's not helping you if you're tired of
going to the doctor and not getting
better if you're concerned that your
medication is shortening your life or
increasing the likelihood of side
effects and adverse reactions or if you
feel tired after you take your
medication or you just don't feel right
after you take your medication please
let me encourage you get on the
nutritional stuff the healthy start pack
get on a nutritional supplement program
at least get on the beyond tagging
tangerine if you're like most folks
you're gonna notice results in 24 to 48
hours and remember the more deficient
the body is the faster it absorbs
nutrients and the better off you're
gonna feel thanks for listening to the
dead doctors don't lie radio program I'm
pharmacist ben for Doug Winfrey for dr.
Wallach for all the folks at the CBS
Radio Network have yourselves a
wonderful beautiful awesome spectacular
day we'll talk to you all later
bye for now
according to the CDC nearly half of all
Americans take at least one prescription
drug daily for those over the age of 60
almost 40% are taking at least five
medications every day some of those
drugs costing hundreds of dollars most
people struggle to pay for these
expensive drugs but FDI youngevity has
the answer with discount pharmacy cards
you can get a 10% and on some drugs up
to an 85 percent discount up to a 35%
discount on hearing aids and up to a 60%
discount on lab tests even ones for your
pets this card never expires and best of
all the FDI youngevity card is free
that's right I said free imagine the
change in your life with extra change in
your pocket all because you're saving
hundreds if not thousands on your
medical costs with your FDI youngevity
discount card contact your local FDI
your jeopardy associate and find out how
you could get your free pharmacy
discount card and remember it's free